welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Kate Baldwin assistant professor of
political science her current research
projects examine how community level
institutions interact with the national
state to affect development democracy
and conflict with a regional focus on
sub-saharan Africa she has published
articles in the american political
science review and the american journal
of political science today we talk with
her about her book project about the
paradox of hereditary Chiefs in
democratic Africa welcome professor
Baldwin thank you so much for having me
so let's begin with an overview of your
book tell us about it okay well in
Africa one of the most important recent
development has been the spread of
democracy in the past two decades so at
the national level at least most
governments are now democratic in the
sense at least that they are elected
they compete in competitive elections
but at the same time at the local level
many communities are still governed by
unelected traditional leaders and what's
more if we look across Africa these
leaders actually seem to have more
influence in the countries that are more
democratic at the national level and so
this is sort of both puzzling in a bit
concerning because how democratic can
these countries really be if they're
still at the local level people are the
citizens are interacting with unelected
leaders and so the motivation for the
project was really trying to understand
what is the impact of these traditional
Chiefs on democratic accountability and
maybe more centrally do these
traditional Chiefs undermine democratic
representation and the answer I provide
is actually a little bit
counterintuitive in that it turns out
that these local Chiefs who are
unelected and have significant careers
of power they actually facilitate
democratic representation rural areas
insofar as the central bureaucracy in
Africa is so weak that elected
representatives aren't able to implement
programming and policies that voters
want without their assistance ha ok it's
very interesting so what led you to
write the book so when I first set off
to do this research project i arrived in
Zambia and I really wasn't intending to
research traditional Chiefs at all so
I'm a political scientist and I was
really interested in the institutions by
which rural citizens got access to state
resources and you know because of my
training I was sort of looking for maybe
the role of political parties or the
formal state bureaucracy but when I got
on the ground in Zambia I found out that
in rural areas these institutions didn't
really exist the way I expected them to
and so political parties were largely
absent in in rural areas that were not
very active there was also very little
presence of the central government
agencies in remote areas instead on a
day-to-day level the people who are
governing these communities were
traditional chief so if a rural Zambian
has a problem the person who they're
most likely to take it to is their
village headman or maybe the traditional
chief who is above him if they have a
dispute with a neighbor they're most
likely to take it to the Chiefs court so
this was both you know surprising in it
for a political scientist there's been
very little written in political science
about the role of traditional chiefs and
even social scientists more generally
haven't done very much research on how
traditional Chiefs effects like the
national political process but it was
also just seemed like a really important
question because as I mentioned earlier
yeah how democratic can countries be if
at the local level citizens are still
mainly interacting with on elected
leaders right okay so why don't you tell
us what exactly a traditional chief is
and what their role in the community is
okay so first of all I want to emphasize
when I use the term traditional chief I
don't mean to imply that that their
position is sort of timeless and
unchanging so I think of traditional
Chiefs as Chiefs who have power by
virtue of their association with the
customs of their community so
they're popularly thought of being
related to tradition but this doesn't
mean that position hasn't changed over
time in fact during the colonial period
there you know the positions of these
leaders did change greatly the trip the
colonial state recognized some leaders
pre-existing leaders and they didn't
recognize others they generally changed
their powers during this time period and
in fact traditional she's got quite a
bad reputation in the late colonial
period so that the independence era
leaders for the most part were had very
negative attitudes towards them at worst
they viewed them as traders who have
been complicit in the colonial project
and at best they just sort of viewed
them as these sort of anachronistic
leaders who they thought would sort of
fade away into the sunset with time but
fast forward you know at to the last 20
years and actually we see that
traditional Chiefs still exist across
much of Africa and at the local level
they still are very important actors so
if they run run court systems they often
play an important role in allocating
land and they play a really important
role in organizing community
contributions to local projects so we
might think of this kind of as
organizing informal taxes so if a
community needs to come together and
build a school or to maintain a road
it's typically the chief who will fund
raise or organize the community to
provide free labor for the project and
so their Chiefs know they exist across
much of sub-saharan Africa and what's
more they seem to be more important at
the local level in the more democratic
countries and this is a little bit you
know why would this be but to take a
step back and think about it in the post
and independence period there were very
few elected governments in Africa and
what that actually meant was that for
the most part politicians could ignore
the the plight of rural citizens the
rural majority could be ignored because
these politicians weren't facing
elections the introduction of
competitive elections means all of a
sudden these leaders need to figure out
a way to win votes sugar rural voters
and what do rural voters want the
product gets very basic things you know
what they want schools and clinics and
roads and wells there is the state is so
weak in so much of rural Africa that
these elected politicians don't have a
mechanism for responding to to these
demands on their own there are state
bureaucracies they can rely on to to to
organize these projects elected leaders
could try to go to these communities and
initiate things by themselves but it
turns out that's also difficult for them
they have obligations perhaps in the
capital city that they need to attend to
and they elected leaders are generally
in office for only a short period of
time so they don't necessarily have the
local level institutions that they can
use to organize communities to provide
projects and so this is where
traditional leaders come in and they
actually pay a really important role in
facilitating the work of elected leaders
especially in so far as a lot of
resources and projects the way that
they're provided in in rural Africa is
through what co-produced co-production
so the central state provide some
resources and the communities are also
expected to provide some resources for
the projects and so the organization of
the community labor or the community
fundraising and General Electric
auditions aren't that effective at doing
that on their own this is where they
turn to traditional cheeks and
traditional cheese can help them out
okay our traditional Chiefs given any
kind of compensation for their role in
the community um so that really varies
widely across my country I think it's
important to note that the reason why
these traditional Chiefs can do this is
I don't want to take a romanticized view
of them as as as these actors who are
you know totally selfless and just care
about their community where are they
different from elected politicians is
not so much in their motivations we can
think both of them is being quite
self-interested but traditional Chiefs
you know are inherit their positions
they live in their communities for lives
and they they're so their economic
well-being is very much tied up with
that of their
local community so as a result they have
an incentive to organize communities to
come together and provide their
contributions to projects because
they're going to benefit in the long run
if their communities welfare improves
where they differ from you know let the
politicians again is in the length of
their time horizon so an elected
politician might want to be able to
provide a school right now but they may
not not expect to be in power you know
ten years down the road and so they
don't have the same incentive to
organize sort of create institutions
that allow the community to work
together collectively traditional Chiefs
by virtue of their longer time horizons
do you have an incentive to do this so
by virtue of you know on an individual
level and also the longer length of time
these traditional institutions have just
existed over time these institutions can
facilitate the elected politicians work
at the local level typically are
hereditary Chiefs in position in that
position until they die I mean how long
do they stay in the role so um again
there is slight variation but in general
most chiefs are selected for life and it
is you know they would have to do
something very egregious in order to be
removed prior to death okay how did you
do the research so what countries did
you look at so and at traditional teas
are sort of an unusual topic for
political scientists and one of the
challenges I had you know in trying to
develop this research design was I
developing a design that both allowed me
sort of to understand complexity of
their roles while also being able to
generalize across cases so the way i did
this is sort of through a multi-tiered
approach so at the narrowest and deepest
level my book project builds on research
that was done at two sites in zambia one
in the northern province and one in the
eastern province and in Zambia is a
central african country it's very poor
it's landlocked it has a ghastly strong
history of competitive elections so
since nineteen
d 1 there have been numerous
presidential and parliamentary elections
and actually there's the government
turnover so we have competitive
elections at the national level but in
rural Zambia there's still you know
almost 300 Chiefs who have quite a bit
of insolence at the local level and I'm
sorry to interrupt is there one chief /
town for instance so Chiefs um on
average you can think of them as
controlling territories that are much
bigger than towns but the populations
with believing at 10,000 you know and so
they're geographically designated in
Zambia and so that these two research
sites and again so it was in the eastern
and the northern region of the province
of the country and I conducted extensive
research so I you know did household
surveys interviews with the chief I
spend a lot of time in those communities
I have my own observations and then but
from there I wanted to be able to you
know reach out and generalize beyond
that so in three provinces of Zambia I
conducted a comprehensive interviews
with all of the traditional chiefs and
those three provinces there are seven
rural provinces in database that was
about half of them and I interviewed a
large proportion of the elected
politicians from those provinces to then
I want to generalize a little beyond
that too so I relied on data from the
ministries in in the capital of Zambia
lusaka and the archives to create a data
set that actually covers all of the
Chiefs in in Zambia from the period
which competitive elections were
reintroduced in 1991 to the present and
and then finally I wanted to be able to
see something beyond Zambia too and so I
also test some of the implications of
the theory I developed cross nationally
using data that we've collected by other
people for the most part in other
countries okay so let's talk a little
bit about the the broader implications
so um I think at the so
the research shows that in many ways the
role of Chiefs is more positive than
many people have suggested and so I
think there's sort of two important
findings that come out of the research
for the book so first I think one of
those important findings is actually
sort of a negative finding many people
have thought that traditional Chiefs can
deliver voters on blocked whichever
political party they choose which would
be really damaging for democratic
accountability would sort of suggest
that voters can be too you know forced
to vote for whoever the chief prefers
without any consideration of their own
interest and actually the research
suggests that that's not the case you
know for the most part people in
understand that their vote is secret
they may feel obliged to obey the Chiefs
instructions in certain realms but they
don't necessarily think they have to
obey them in the political realm so I
want to have that sort of a very
positive thing for democratic
accountability second as I already
alluded to these cheese's play a really
important role in facilitating
democratic accountability in so far as
they sort of help elected politicians
implement programming at the very local
level in community so this is sort of
like central paradox of the book these
unelected leaders facilitate the work of
elected leaders then but nope there are
also there there are some cons as well
for generational change and so obviously
the situation where electric politicians
need to rely on these unelected
traditional Chiefs to implement local
programming is not ideal compared to a
situation where they could instead rely
on a neutral meritocratic bureaucracy
but in the short term that's not an
option so I don't think that you know
that criticism I think we can push aside
at least in the short term a more
serious criticism is because traditional
chief sort of provide the stopgap or
almost band-aid solution allowing
politicians to deliver resources to
rural communities without a strong
bureaucracy they prevent they reduce the
incentive to invest in
lengthening bureaucracy and in the long
run that might actually be a much more
effective way it probably would be a
more effective way of delivering these
resources and providing programming to
people in rural Africa so so you know
they sort of this short term long term
trade-off here okay well very
fascinating stuff I have to say thank
you so much for being here today and
sharing center of your work thank you
very much for having me for more
information about professor Baldwin
enter work please visit our website at
yale edu slash mcmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale
you